[Music]
in anything for mother News submitted by
Yelp reviewers a loving son disguised
himself as his mother to take her
driving test on her behalf
oh that's cute also sounds hella
dangerous like that ladies - dahveed
right if she can't even show up for the
test that's what I'm thinking yeah
there's a lot of people on the roads
that shouldn't be driving no not so cute
for them yeah I think all people should
have the driver's licenses to [ __ ]
take in a way or retest it like every
year put them in an auto car dude and
guess what if the auto car system isn't
ready yet even better and I think there
should be a comment I think should be a
common-sense test where like they take
them on the freeway uh-huh and let's say
the speed limit 65 but there's no cars
ahead of them see if they go 65 under 65
or if they go 80 you're gonna lose your
license if they go 80 cool this guy's
good common sense uh-huh what you're a
shitty driver not if I pay attention
part is an exactly terrible driver
and it's you've been in the car with him
many times it's very scary experience
yeah I'm only a good driver when I'm not
paying attention this is some [ __ ]
thinking she's a good driver honestly
yes but she's a terrifying [ __ ]
person to have by me it's just cuz I'm
baby driver you ever seen that movie
that's me you drive really fast yeah and
I can like and then I just kind of like
I get where I want to go and I get there
efficiently I'm so scared for me
sometimes I'd just feel like singing
while I do it cuz I have to be the
stretch I feel baby Jeffery the way that
oh yeah exactly yeah she executed
maneuvers I can feel weeks being taken
off of my life stress a chance to fall
asleep with a car like he wakes up right
as I'm like switching lanes and so it
looks like we're about to crash into the
car in front of us but oh Jesus
like you sleep and then she's like tada
not a good trick
shouldn't you shouldn't accelerate into
someone's bumper they call me the
miracle man who's 43 year old man he has
been caught wearing an old woman's
disguised as he was trying to take his
mom's driving test for her because she
had failed it three times already
yes she's 60 by the way oh I'm sorry and
she was 15
I don't know what 60 minus 43 17 18 so
the mom did not know that he was up to
this because she she had been
complaining to him that she was
struggling to take her driving test she
was just really stressed out about it so
he wanted to help her out and so he
thought this was the best way to do it
instead of like trying to teach her how
to drive properly so anyway this is the
son well with the mom with that Jonathas
Amma this is what he looked like really
good ballsy that's because the woman
that was doing the driving test like she
looked at the ID and then looked at him
she was like that's not you yeah
oh my god I was like just like that he
got the most attended DMV driver how
come I get the one who doesn't give a
[ __ ] if you're even alive wasn't that a
good thing yeah it would be it would be
in this case yes oh then he even did his
nails because he did it so good I want
him to have passed I know I am doing
pass I don't like her on the road
I'm in the story now and I want I want
the bag I'd win I think he's a [ __ ]
serial killer now but does he go to jail
for this you go to jail for this right
country though all right yeah so it's in
Brazil and so they once a woman
recognize that it wasn't the same person
and from the ID he she did call the cops
and he was arrested man accused of fraud
and misuse of someone's identity and
then once they questioned him like why
would you do this
he ended up confessing that he is that's
his mom and she was just trying to help
out his mom out of love I like how it
always turns into a shark tank sob story
right it's like the cops arrest somebody
and then when they finally break about
what they were up to it's always that
shark tank like listen man I'm doing
this because my family my mama that's
like every reality TV thing Undercover
Boss exactly that show has no rewatch
ability you watched Undercover Boss one
time you saw all of it at least Shark
Tank there are different [ __ ]
Chisholm's huh yeah and then sometimes
it's really bad and it's pretty fun I
like the bad ones that's 1984 I like to
do that ready make me go like this I
love that whew did you see that one
where the guy was trying to pitch them a
pyramid scheme really yeah this dude
came on shark tank and was like hey like
I want you to bring bring you into this
like business that I have and then
basically pitched a pyramid scheme and
they were like that's a pyramid scheme
it's like no because the money comes
from here they're like yeah but where
does that money come from he's like it
comes from these people at the bottom
one would say it's a pyramid he's like
no whenever somebody's like hey we got
these copper fittings that make your
joints all and Mark Cuban goes [ __ ]
boulders dick he's always like that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] horseshit [ __ ] none of
that's backed by science [ __ ] you man
he's like Beasley starts he's like what
you wanna [ __ ] I know about all this
[ __ ] okay we got a minute she's is
Christ the guy go so much fun meaning
you find it unlike all the little like
it's like ABC right
the hula Scouts is like Amazon and HBO's
dreams like anything that you have to
buy an extra subscription to is just
part of the who's like probably how this
man sounded he was tried in prison yo I
want to hear the voice that you wouldn't
touch it was actually trying really hard
as natural as possible and he was a very
like confident and his getup it's sweet
yeah he even wore women's jewelry damn
did that for you you look like you
that's true
I think grand drag taking the driving
test that's cute she's like 16 he's 47
or 44 343 cute maybe give it away when
you went to the men's bathroom an outfit
like I wonder for maybe maybe he's still
selling it he goes to the men's rather
he realizes he does that and he sits on
the urine like it would have passed in
mrs. Doubtfire
like right yeah like that's your
ex-husband you don't recognize okay I
know it's crazy
goofy yes well 90s movies you gotta have
have a little bit magic in there yeah so
if it was like a 90s movie this would
all work but I don't know kind of bugged
me cuz it's like listen that's cute and
all but your mother should not be on the
road what are you doing she's not
passing these tests maybe he's [ __ ]
tired of hearing her nag about how she's
[ __ ] feeling it was like both men are
driving her ass everywhere
he's a mechanic too it's like oh so you
wanted more business you're just
following her car looking like business
cards along the way follow the money
I do wish the drivers test was way way
way harder so it could weed out way more
people on the road how would you make it
harder I don't know maybe like I think
you miss like 13 or something I felt
what it was but like about the actual
project there's a
santé mound that you can miss yeah like
I should be miss maybe like three things
and you don't get your license a lot of
people get pulled over for driving slow
as [ __ ] - I heard they do I'd never seen
a non la they got bigger fish to fry
yeah never seen it you get uh what does
it call punished for being a racecar
driver where like if you're really good
at driving fast and you get to swerve
and move they should give you a word or
something cuz that's why I Drive like
[ __ ] is cuz I'm so bored so I'm like oh
[ __ ] yeah that's not I'm just gonna
happen one one eye open like you know I
was driving and then she was like she
knows I'm driving and then her
notification goes off because she I just
posted on Instagram and she goes and
looks at you wait there's [ __ ] this
photos hell edited and there's like a
long-ass [ __ ] caption and she's like
did you edit this photo and write this
caption while you're driving make up
that's the only like a drive safely
that's all [ __ ] on camera I guess yeah
she won't admit this crime on camera
interesting relevation I'm a really good
driver yeah yeah my dad would you be
like I can only drive well if I'm drunk
straight face - no yeah no he was there
was always like a bottle of beer open
bottle like what what's the punishment
for like duis in Mexico didn't he live
here for one year and you lived your
whole life in Mexico
but yes it was close don't you live in
Mexico right now I do actually yeah I do
oh no pretty they're just just
telecommuting this is actually a
hologram we edited in post
no I just I have that much time and
money so yeah
chopper hey goober Arella copter oh yeah
lady I want to know what his mom
actually look yeah me too I was chosen
because that's convincing to me like my
mind yeah and then you know how I said
that the mom didn't knows cuz she was in
another state in Brazil and then so I
can only imagine how she found out about
this cuz this thing went viral in Brazil
so imagine like just scrolling through
social media and seeing your son dressed
up as you yeah try doing it as a sweet
surprise so a birthday surprise yeah I
think he was waiting for her to be gone
and he could do I'll guess what I got
your license would you be happier
terrified at that point what the hell
did you do actually I'd be a little bit
pissed because what if you passed it and
they let him get the whole license and
everything and then you have to take a
photo for your license
yeah you get the license to drive IV
pissed cuz the system failed I'm like
god dammit just means this this could
happen everywhere it does happen hold
ladies on the freeway just like Oh whose
son do you wonder if that DMV worker got
a bonus Oh true justice that's how my
uncle got his citizenship way faster he
found out if you go instead of going
like the regular immigrant application
Arella if you go like you have a
handicap or whatever route so he
pretended to have like this injury and
he got away faster my dad's on this
story you would think they would want
able-bodied people way faster know what
it is that's what he told me well thing
up for JK news where you can tell
everyone how your dad fake being hey
yeah game not my dad isn't really
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]